[Musique]
il est beaucoup plus facile de faire de
la dette le qui sera réglée par nous
plus tard par nos enfants plus tard les
pays les plus pauvres ne rembourseront
pas donc garder une créance dans le
bilan au passé qu'elle sera jamais
remboursé c'est c'est même pas hypocrite
ça n'a pas de sens on a pas de
croissance et on a une dette qu'ils ont
fait il n'y a pas la maîtrise de nos
têtes on est effectivement à la main à
nos créanciers
vous appartenez à celui qui me prêtent
de l'argent ce soit l'état soit une
banque mais vous lui appartenait
totalement pour christine lagarde la
patronne de la bce l'animation de la
dette ne serait ce que partiel est
totalement impensable c'est pas si
facile 2 nuls et la dette et la limite
ses poires
c'est la planche à billets qui aura en
contrepartie
[Musique]
devenez
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour une heure et demie d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenus à bonne distance bien
évidemment et nos reporters sur le
terrain
l'actualité a toujours dominé par la
crise du coronavirus en france et dans
le monde
voici les titres sanofi appelle l'europe
à partager les risques pour produire un
vaccin le laboratoire a provoqué une
levée de boucliers en laissant entendre
que les etats unis bénéficierait du
vaccin en premier même le patron
français a tenté de rassurer en
affirmant qu'il serait accessible à tous
en même temps
emmanuel être on juge nécessaire que ce
vaccin soit un bien public mondial
extraits des lois du marché oui nous
pourrons partir en vacances en france en
juillet et août c'est ce qu'annonce le
premier ministre sous réserve bien sûr
de l'évolution de l'épidémie au
quelqu'un il y aurait des remboursement
est garanti
alors que le secteur du tourisme est
touchée de plein fouet par la crise et
loire philippe à promettre un plan de
relance massif avec un engagement de 18
milliards d'euros
[Musique]
en italie ce sont des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs clandestins qui
vont être régularisés une mesure loin de
faire l'unanimité mais jugé
indispensable par giuseppe compter face
à la menace qui pèse sur les récoltes
aux états unis donald trump menace
désormais de rompre avec toute relation
avec le géant asiatique qu'il juge
responsable de l'apparition du virus
[Musique]
la question du retour au travail après
le déconfinement de l'action en justice
de la cgt contre une usine de reuze nos
propositions chocs de l'institut
montaigne pour rebondir
les vieilles querelles ressurgissent
alors devront nous dire adieu aux congés
payés ou rtt faudra-t-il travailler plus
pour gagner moins
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre à toutes ces questions dans
l'édito est qu à 21h15
[Musique]
qui aura le premier axe est un éventuel
vaccin contre le coc vie 19 la question
était sur toutes les lèvres aujourd'hui
un ennui elle l'est d'ailleurs toujours
parmi les laboratoires dans les starting
blocks pour le produire le français
sanofi et mais son directeur général a
mis le feu aux poudres aujourd'hui
suggérant un accès prioritaire pour les
états unis
les explications de cyrielle benavides
bulgare l'annoncé a eu l'effet d'une
bombe lancée dans la course au vaccin
contre le coronavirus depuis le mois de
février
sanofi n'a pas tardé à créer la
polémique avec cette déclaration
j'ai fait campagne en europe pour dire
que les états unis recevront les vaccins
en premier c'est comme ça parce qu'ils
ont investis pour essayer de protéger
leurs populations et redémarrer leurs
économies une attribution du est un
partenariat entre le laboratoire
français et l'autorité américaine de
recherche et de développement avancée
dans le domaine biomédical un organisme
qui dépend du ministère américain de la
santé et qui aurait versé une trentaine
de millions d'euros à sanofi pour
assurer la recherche d'un vaccin et
permettrait donc un accès prioritaire
aux états unis des propos auxquels
emmanuel macron réagi rapidement
la déclaration du patron de sanofi a
beaucoup ému le président de la
république car ce vaccin doit être un
bien public mondial et être extrait des
lois du marché et une situation qui
suscite un tollé au sein de la classe
politique française parce que la santé
est un bien commun à soustraire au jeu
du marché
aucune entreprise française ne doit
pouvoir jouer contre notre propre
souveraineté sanitaires sans s'exposer à
une nationalisation
sanofi annonce qu'en cas de découverte
d'un vaccin il l'offrira d'abord aux usa
scandale sanitaire social et économique
en disant sanofi a touché 1 milliards
5,2 c hier des millions de cic eu sa
recherche est subventionné par de
l'argent public français honteux il est
impensable qu'une entreprise qui a son
siège en france et qui bénéficient de
crédits d'impôt recherche des livres
un vaccin aux états unis avant nous vous
devez agir
sanofi pdg surpayés licenciement nuisant
à l'activité
évident de records maintenant absence de
patriotisme ce laboratoire symbolise ce
que le capitalisme fait de pires un
vaccin doit profiter à toutes et à tous
sans négociation la commission
européenne a également averti que
l'accès au vaccin devraient être
universels une pression sur le groupe
qu'il le pousse à revenir sur sa
décision
tout en rappelant que la france et
l'europe devraient participer davantage
pour en tirer les bénéfices
j'ai appelé le pdg de sanofi france pour
lui demander des explications et il m'a
dit que ça ne reflétait pas du tout la
politique de son laboratoire et qu'il
avait communiqués ce qu'il a d'ailleurs
fait pour bien expliquer que toutes les
populations qui doivent bénéficier du
vaccin bénéficieront du vaccin
une rencontre est d'ores et déjà prévu
lyon début de semaine prochaine entre
l'elysée et les dirigeants de sanofi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
nicolas dupont aignan président de
debout la france bonsoir nicolas dupont
aignan merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france est ce que ça nous fit
nous appris aujourd'hui ce qu'on savait
peut-être déjà mais que finalement nous
ne sommes pas tous égaux devant le vexin
bonsoir à vous sanofi s'est comporté de
manière scandaleuse
j'ai regardé les profits de sanofi 2018
sur 34 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
un taux de résultat net de six milliards
8 c'est-à-dire 20%
c'est colossal cela veut dire que cette
entreprise qui fait des profits
exorbitants sur le dos d'ailleurs des
contribuables français à travers leurs
cotisations sociales pour acheter des
médicaments car je vous rappelle que
s'il y a des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques c'est parce qu'on cotise
et donc ça ne fait aujourd'hui 10 les
etats-unis ont mis trente millions vous
devez mettre un peu mais quelle honte
quelle honte
c'est une honte absolue voilà donc ça
prouve aussi qu'on a laissé faire depuis
tant d'années les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques se constituer en
puissance c'est le l'abandon de l'êta
l'abandon de la volonté politique
capitalisme
totalement dévoyé et à force de ne
jamais réagir mais ils se permettent
tout voilà alors sanofi a repris la
parole un peu plus tard dans l'après
midi
d'une certaine manière renvoyer la balle
à l'europe
en dix ans on a besoin de partager les
risques pour produire les doses d'un
potentiel vaccin est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que ça soit légitime même si ce
n'est pas politiquement correct les
états unis financent beaucoup l'europe -
donc ils seront servis en premier je me
fais évidemment l'avocat du diable mais
c'est en tout cas l'argument avancé par
le laboratoire mais moi j'aimerais que
le laboratoire nous disent combien les
etats-unis ont mis sur la table et je
trouve très choquant de la part d'un
laboratoire qui accumule autant de
profits voilà donc c'est complètement
ahurissant cet argument ne tient pas un
instant et s'agissant en plus d'une
entreprise française qui bénéficient de
milliards de crédit d'impôt recherche
donc maintenant ça suffit et la vraie
question c'est pourquoi les médicaments
sont produits par des entreprises
privées
on peut s'interroger pourquoi pas
nationalisées s'il le faut maintenant ça
suffit et il est temps d'arrêter avec
ces féodalités privé ces multinationales
qui encore une fois se croient tout
permis moi je respecte la libre
concurrence
mais j'en ai assez que le rompre il
attise toujours les profits et que l'on
rende publiques les pertes
donc si je comprends bien l'état devrait
encore payer pour que sanofi fassent
encore plus de profits sur le dos des
malades
maintenant ça suffit alors il ya un
autre élément en tout cas c'est une
information de la part des syndicats
sanofi qui toucherait sont le seul ont
eu 110 à 130 millions d'euros de la part
de l'état au titre du crédit impôt
recherche
enfin monsieur yee cee et du crédit
d'impôt compétitivité un allègement
fiscal controversé qui a été mis en
place sous françois hollande ça
donnerait quelques obligations
mais bien sûr ce que je vous dis je vous
dis à sanofi à des profits exorbitants
sanofi a délocalisé les productions pour
augmenter sa marge et moi j'ai une
proposition que je fais depuis des
années
qui est très simple que les les
médicaments remboursés par la sécurité
sociale soit fabriqué en france voilà
alors effectivement parce qu'on peut pas
demander si extraordinaire avec ses
entreprises
on peut pas demander à ces entreprises
en fait ces entreprises voudraient avoir
les lois du marché avec des crédits
publics alors mêmes émotions on paye de
médicaments à partir des cotisations
sociales
on les fabrique en france pardonnez-nous
ya un petit délai effectivement ce qui
rend parfois compliqué la conversation
et leon les relances l'essai de vous
poser les questions de nous laisser
répondre en raison ce délai emmanuel
macron en tout cas lui veut qu'un
éventuel vaccin soit un bien public
extraits des lois du marché ce que selon
vous c'est un voeu pieux est ce que
c'est un but qui peut être réalisable
concrètement c'est l'évidence cela
devrait être naturel maintenant le
problème des manuels macron sait que
c'est lui qui a laissé les entreprises
tout faire c'est lui qui leur a donné
des milliards sans contrepartie et après
ils pleurent sur la situation
nous nous avons toujours été cohérent à
debout la france j'ai toujours demandé
que quand il ya des crédits publics et
bien il ya une contrepartie
voilà donc s'ils veulent pas de
médicaments remboursés par la sécurité
sociale qui les produisent où il vole
mais quand c'est l'état qui paye parce
que c'est nous qui payons quand je dis
l'état c'est nous un scellé français bah
c'est quand même normal se soit produit
en france si vous saviez qu'il ya
actuellement 27 milliards de
remboursements de sécurité sociale de
médicaments 27 milliards par an et on a
laissé délocaliser parce que c'est
tellement facile de dire quand on va
produire en inde le taux de marge va
doubler ou tripler
j'ai pas si vous réalisez ce que
représente un taux de marge de 20% pour
une entreprise dans l'industrie lourde
les pme c'est des taux de marges quoi de
2 3% 4%
sanofi ses 20% donc ils l'ont fait
comment on manque aujourd'hui
médicaments dans nos hôpitaux
vous savez que 35 anticancéreux
médicaments anticancéreux principaux ne
sont plus fabriqués en europe donc
il faut absolument relocaliser tant
qu'on ne re localisera pas on sera
dépendant voilà aujourd'hui clairement
les états unis pratiquent un patriotisme
forcené on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec la
sphère des masques je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez également le vaccin
que souhaite présenter clairement les
états unis ne s'en sont pas cachés est
ce que ça vous choque qu'on devrait
finalement faire la même chose en france
mais bien sûr au lieu d'accuser les
autres il faudrait faire la même chose
mais vous savez on a des nuls
ce sont des nuls suis désolé de le dire
dans ces termes mais quand vous pensez
que pour acheter des masques qu'ils
n'ont pas été capables de les acheter
comptant évidemment avec des appels
d'offres des complications des acomptes
en chine ils ont vendu à ce qu'ils leur
payait les masques il ya un moment il
faut se défendre
donc moi je je demande à la france mais
ça fait des années qu'on parle de
patriotisme économique et mais on ne
fait pas d'ailleurs personne ne le sait
mais pendant qu'il ya cette crise du coc
vide 19 l'union européenne a continué à
signer des accords de libre-échange
déloyaux avec le mexique et avec
d'autres d'autres pays donc ça veut dire
que il ya un double langage permanent
c'est à dire que on voit les dégâts
d'une mondialisation inhumaine je suis
pas contre les échanges il faut le juste
échange
et on va pas vivre refermer sur soi mais
il faut un juste échange
et donc pendant qu'on se plaint des
dégâts de la mondialisation inhumaine
on continue on continue donc la vraie
question c'est la cohérence
moi je demande en politique ce que je
demande c'est la cohérence
j'essaie d'être cohérent ce que je dis
j'essaye de proposer des choses en
cohérence avec ce que je dis le problème
c'est que ça fait 20 ans qu'on est
gouverné par des des gens qui en fait
disent quelque chose et font linverse et
c'est pourquoi il ya plus comment dire
de confiance politique et les français
ne retrouveront la confiance politique
que quand les hommes politiques diront
la vérité avec ses inconvénients et ses
avantages
moi je vais pas vous dire que de
produire en france sera moins cher
peut-être que il faudra faire plus
d'efforts mais au moins on produire en
france et ça fera des emplois et ça fera
la sécurité dans nos hôpitaux
vous savez que nos hôpitaux manquaient
de tout de blues
tout ça parce que certaines entreprises
font du profit sur le dos de la
collectivité
merci beaucoup à nicolas dupont aignan
président de debout la france d'avoir
réagi en direct sur rt france le premier
ministre edouard philippe au chevet du
tourisme très secoué vous le savez par
la crise ducobu 19 le secteur
attendaient des mesures dead avec
impatience c'est chose faite
le gouvernement promet un pan de soutien
de 18 milliards d'euros d'engagements
l'enjeu économique est considérable
puisque le secteur emploie plus de 2
millions de personnes et génère plus de
cette pension du pib le premier ministre
a aussi déclaré que les français
pourront partir en vacances dans le pays
en juillet et en août qui les a
encouragés à réserver et principales
annonces en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quelles sont les réactions dans le
secteur pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec olivier
occelli directeur de l'office du
tourisme de bordeaux en direct également
avec bruno cappellari patron des chefs
du restaurant l'harmonie à sérignan dans
l'hérault bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour réagir donc à ces énoncés
mesures présentées par edouard philippe
edouard philippe qui rappelle un peu le
tourisme fait probablement face à la
pire épreuve de son histoire moderne est
ce que vous avez clairement été rassurés
aujourd'hui on commence par vous olivier
occelli aimait écouter
oui en tout cas ces aides sont vraiment
à la hauteur de la crise que l'on
traverse aujourd'hui on peut dire que
voilà s'il ya des mesures à court terme
à moyen terme à long terme parce que la
période de reprise va être très longue
pour le tourisme donc oui ces annonces
ont été à la hauteur
autre réaction dont bruno cappellari
vous est on le rappelle un patron et
chef d'un restaurant on imagine que
c'est effectivement très compliqué enfin
hausse et un pour les restaurants
largement rassurés par les annonces du
premier ministre aujourd'hui l'assuré
c'est pas vraiment le mot pour moi je
pense que je reste quand même un petit
peu sceptique
partagé entre la joie d'effectivement de
retrouver collaborateurs nos clients
la joie de cuisine et parce que ça va
s'cauet mortiers maintenant un petit peu
la peur des contraintes qui peuvent nous
tomber dessus on n'a pas être cahier des
charges en bois ouvrir soit six ans dans
deux semaines donc ça va être très
compliqué je pense
il faut espérer que tout se passe bien
jusque-là déjà et voir comment ils
retrouver notre clientèle ce n'est
peut-être pas olivier occelli cette
inquiétude de la part d'un autre ami
restaurateur de ne pas retrouver la
clientèle pour vous allez elle est
fondée oui tout à fait on est dans
l'expectative de en effet de cette
réouverture avec des conditions qui vont
être compliqués c'est vrai que sur des
destinations comme bordeaux la clientèle
internationale ne sera pas présente sur
cet été donc ça sera quand même des
grands manques à gagner en effet pour
pour le secteur ça veut dire quoi
concrètement messieurs que ce plan pour
vous il est très franco français pour
l'instant
on rappelle quand même des points
importants à chômage partiel jusqu'à fin
septembre cours à l'activité partielle
impossible jusqu'à fin 2020 la sphère
des tickets restaurant qu'on va pouvoir
ça paraît anodin comme l'expliqué à
edouard philippe mais voilà qu'on pourra
utiliser le week-end avec des plafonds
élevé ça reste très français pour vous
aussi trop français peut-être bruno
cappellari oui c'est tout aussi français
que la firme a toujours qu'on nous a
fait faire effectivement le 14 mars en
nous annonçant à 19h camille lui il
fallait fermer on a les mêmes
problématiques pour la couverture c'est
moi c'est vraiment ce qui m'inquiète le
plus rochus en bord de mer donc on a une
grosse clientèle et de l'étranger qu'on
aura pas cette année on va réouvrir avec
le personnel puisque on ne peut pas
travailler sans malheureusement on
fabrique tout de nombreux restaurants
avec de la matière première fraîches et
des rangs et périssable on va se
retrouver certainement 100 % des charges
avec peut-être 52 40 % de la clientèle
donc ça va être quelque chose qui va
faire très bien géré et certainement des
charges supplémentaires avec nathan
forcément des visières des masques ou
des gels et je pense qu'on ne s'est pas
encore assez pour vraiment explosé de
joie sur cette réouverture qui pourrait
effectivement vous nous dites avec assez
d'assurance tous les deux que y aura pas
de clientèle étrangère vous avez eu des
informations qu'on n'aurait pas parce
que sauf erreur de ma part pour le
moment il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas mais
peut-être que juillet et août on on
pourra vous ne restez pas optimiste si
je reste optimiste en juillet août on
arrive déjà à 8 c sur la fin de la
saison quand même parce que je t'aime
faut dire que le reste les saisons sont
de plus en plus courtes et plus en plus
compliqué pour tout le monde
en effet il ya eu un manque à gagner
très fort sur le printemps et les lignes
aériennes malheureusement son sont
complètement stoppée et il va falloir
des mois plusieurs mois pour que les
lignes aériennes reprennent alors il ya
quand même une bonne nouvelle on
latrines peut-être pas assez c'est que
les français sont clairement incités en
laye a eu d'ailleurs un rétropédalage du
gouvernement puisque ministre de la
santé nous avait dit surtout ne
réservait pas les vacances et la edouard
philippe me disent ici vous pouvez y
aller est allé en france on vous
garantit même des remboursement complet
en cas d'empêchement à cause de
l'épidémie c'est une bonne chose ça
notamment sur le bassin d'arcachon
on rappelle que vous gérez les hôtels
les restaurations olivier occelli et non
je ne gère pas mes chiots relier en tout
cas avec les acteurs du tourisme n'ont
pas de problèmes locaux oui c'est une
très bonne chose
nous on mise beaucoup sur la clientèle
nationale on revoit toute notre offre
notamment de visites guidées de tous les
acteurs du tourisme recours or mettent
en oeuvre leur offre pour cette
clientèle nationale et même pour la
clientèle locale le tourisme de
proximité pour les week-ends à venir
on attend beaucoup de ce tourisme de
proximité bien sont bien entendu ça ne
compensera pas les manques à gagner au
niveau international mais on espère que
les français vont vouloir redécouvrir
leur ville
leur territoire est en tout cas on met
tout en oeuvre pour cela et bruno
cappellari ça vous a compris que soulagé
cette incitation clairement à consommer
français cet été encouragés tout
simplement les français à rester sur le
territoire et à réserver
oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'il en aura un
véritable rôle à nous de les recevoir
comme il se doit de leur présenter nos
régions nos produits nos producteurs
il ya des travaux manifestement c'est
vous ça prépare certainement là la
réouverture est ce que olivier occelli
les restaurants ont fait des
propositions pour s'adapter on sait que
ça parfois on nous parle de voilà comme
dans d'autres pays de plexiglas entre
les tables on imagine que c'est pas
vraiment dans l'esprit très très
français la convivialité
c'est certain la restauration teint hâlé
dit allez-y vous êtes plus à même de
répondre ça correspond pas tout à fait
ou est ce que les clients viennent
rechercher dans des établissements plus
tôt la convivialité et la proche même
envers le personnel de service qui va
leur présenter le vin les assiettes les
produits les donc si on doit commencer à
mettre des plexiglas entre les clients
comme je suis pas si sûr certains
réseaux des cloches qui tombent du
plafond des je sais pas si c'est
vraiment ce que viennent rechercher les
clients restaurant la dernière question
est pour vous puisque vous êtes en
liaison avec on le rappelle ses hôtels
autour de bordeaux le médecin d'arcachon
pour qu'on ait vu clairement la
réouverture est ce qu on a déjà une
petite idée pour même écouter des hôtels
sont déjà ouverts sur bordeaux il est
possible de venir pour séjourner un
week-end en tout cas dans la zone des
100 km aujourd'hui et plus tard on
espère sur juillet-août de les hôtels
vont réouvrir très certainement au fur
et à mesure des semaines à venir des
opérateurs prévoient de ré ouvrir dans
le courant du mois de juin
donc on est prêt pour ce tourisme de
proximité ce tourisme national dans les
semaines à venir d'avoir été
avec nous du côté des écoliers la
rentrée suit son cours avec celle des
élèves de maternelle et de l'élémentaire
à paris ou à lille notamment deuxième
vague des colliers reprendre le chemin
de l'école aujourd'hui avec de nouvelles
règles d'accueil des gestes barrières à
respecter le port du masque obligatoire
pour les enseignants au total d'ici à
demain plus d'un million d'élèves auront
retrouvé leur classe avant le retour des
premiers collégiens la semaine prochaine
en zone verte en ile-de-france région
fortement touchée par l'épidémie notre
reporter nadège abderrazak a assisté ce
matin à la rentrée des classes à
levallois-perret notamment il n'avait
plus mis le pied à l'école depuis deux
mois les élèves de grande section de cp2
cm2 ont donc retrouvé le chemin des
classes par groupe de 15 maximum mesures
de sécurité oblige
après huit semaines de confinement et
c'est un soulagement autant pour les
enfants que pour les parents qui ont
décidé de réintégrer leurs enfants en
classe je suis confiante non j'ai pas
peur dans tous les cas il faut qu'on
continue à vivre et moi mais l'hôpital a
besoin de moi mes patients moi j'ai
besoin aussi de travailler et d'être de
participer je peux pas m'enfermer chez
moi j'ai c'est mon devoir aussi j'ai pas
trop d'inquiétude puisque le couvent il
touche pas tellement les enfants juste
pour nous mais où on l'aura bien briefé
comment protéger les autres voilà moi ça
va faire du bien un peu quand on descend
prendre l'air et je trouve que c'est
bien qu'ils retournent à l'école soulagé
je sais pas on verra comment ça se passe
j'espère que les règles sont respectées
jeu
on verra bien comment ça évolue je n'ai
pas trop m'approcher de mes copains
et je les touche pas on a hésité on ne
savait pas trop comment se positionner
puis l'école nous a bien rassuré par
rapport à ce qui mettait en place donc
voilà on leur fait confiance et
plongeurs et pour pour l'école je suis
pas très inquiète on est là c'est qu'on
est pas encore entré donc il faut qu'on
attende un petit peu mais je pense que
ça devrait aller côté sécurité sanitaire
la mairie de levallois-perret estime
avoir pris toutes les mesures
nécessaires respect d'une distance d'un
mètre entre chaque enfant lavage des
mains régulier à des infections
quotidienne du matériel écouter le maire
de levallois perret d'un grand
soulagement de voir que tout s'est bien
passé
pratiquement tous les enfants sont
rentrés et c'est un grand succès on
l'avait décidé très tôt et c'est le seul
domaine où l'état a pris la main d'une
manière compliquée mais sans doute
indispensable et on a respecté à la
lettre le protocole que l'éducation
nationale à préparer
quand on voit la tête des enfants le
sourire la joie qu'ils ont de se
retrouver de jouer sur les petits trek
nous nous prenons comme des traits de
confinement on n'a pas le droit
d'avancer
eux ils jouent à la marelle dessus le
sourire quand ils retrouvent leurs
enseignants
c'est ce qui nous fait le plus chaud au
coeur a non les enfants pour eux il ya
aucune difficulté avec un nombre
d'élèves réduits et des classes toujours
fermé l'enseignement à distance est
toujours très important d'ailleurs
d'après le ministère de l'éducation
nationale ce dispositif exceptionnel
pourrait se maintenir jusqu'à la rentrée
des classes de septembre si la situation
sanitaire ne s'améliore pas ont repris
scolaires partielles également à lille
aujourd'hui des parents plutôt confiants
ont déposé leurs enfants devant les
écoles réouvertes caroline béhague a
recueilli leurs témoignages ont fait
pleinement confiance à l'organisation
et que la prison ça en charge des
enfants des circuits sont prévus au fait
tous les gestes barrières et c'est donc
au final il ya de la crainte plus sur le
côté pro fin personnellement c'est plus
sur le côté les protocoles soient
respectés
est-ce que ça va pas stresser au final
et dans le fond on puisqu'il enfin toute
cette histoire en fait de compréhension
d'assimilation de distanciation sociale
et des changements qui vont aborder à
l'école ont été informés de ce qu'elle
est mis en place
c'est les sa lé vraiment envie de
repartir à l'école et donc voila c
chez que les mesures de sécurité vont
être pleins
[Musique]
en compte il ya peu d'élèves dans les
classes
donc non je pense que et puis c'était
important qu'ils retournent à l'école
qui revoit les enfants tout ça ce qui me
fais ce qui me faisait un petit peu
parce que je savais pas trop comment il
allait il n'a pas été stressé pendant
tout le confinement est donc là
peut-être de retenue dans son école à
voir tout le monde masqué avec vraiment
les mesures barrières à prendre en
compte je savais pas trop comment voulez
vous on verra bien non non on n'a pas
hésité on n'a pas hésité une seconde
parce que c'était ça fait long et qu' il
était temps pour lui qui retrouve ses
camarades et qui a un cadre scolaire
proche de la normale en avait hâte que
ça puisse reprendre lui aussi en
activité
donc à
de travail le ps par année qui passe
semble du coup à fond
avec les fois la maison dont on est ravi
de savoir qui sera de
jours par semaine
avec lui
et cette tribune publiée hier par le
quotidien du médecin dans laquelle
plusieurs pédiatres pointe du doigt la
nécessité du retour des enfants à
l'école pour leur bien-être distille les
signataires soulignent qu'ils ne sont
pas vecteurs principaux de circulation
du virus est qu un enfant infecté par le
cos vie 19 développe très rarement des
symptômes sévères et fabien un kocher
pédiatre président de l'association
française de pédiatrie ambulatoire fait
partie des signataires de cettre et
lunel et en direct avec nous sur rc
france bonsoir fabienne à coacher merci
d'être avec nous alors c'est une voix
qu'on l'entend assez peu il faut bien le
dire ces derniers temps cette tendance
qui mettait les enfants à l'école bien
au contraire l esi vous êtes bien placé
puisque vous êtes pédiatre pour parler
de ça pour quoi justement avoir voulu
encourager écrire cette tribune
bonsoir l or l'ensemble des sociétés de
pédiatrie milite depuis quelques
semaines pour le retour des enfants à
l'école
tout simplement parce que nous savons
maintenant que les enfants ne sont pas
les victimes de cette épidémie
le cobp et 19 épargne les enfants les
enfants ne sont pas contagieux et ils
peuvent retourner à l'école et les
mesures de distanciation imposé dans le
protocole pour le retour à l'école des
enfants est excessif les mesures
préconisées ne sont pas nécessaires les
enfants n'étant pas particulièrement à
vendanger
la principale mesure barrière à
appliquer et à faire comprendre aux
enfants et il est facile de leur faire
comprendre cette mesure barrière
c'est une hygiène rigoureuse des mains
les enfants doivent savoir qu'il faut
qu'il se lave les mains très souvent le
port du masque n'est pas nécessaire chez
les enfants ils ne sont pas contagieux
entre eux ils ne sont pas contagieux
pour les adultes
naturellement
les adultes porteront le masque à
l'école pour se protéger entre eux et
pour protéger les enfants et par
ailleurs les enfants doivent pouvoir
retrouver une école un visage humain
dans laquelle ils peuvent s'épanouir et
les mesures qui sont prises avec des
enfants que l'on voit isolé auteur à
l'intérieur d'un cercle en cours de
récréation ne nous semble pas compatible
avec un retour à l'école en toute
sécurité pour les enfants les enfants
doivent pouvoir s'épanouir à l'école ils
ont besoin de bouger ils ont besoin de
retrouver leur école d'avant vous êtes
en train de faire c'est important parce
qu'il ya eu tellement de choses dit tout
et son contraire que finalement la
plupart des enfants qui sont affectés
par le cos vite le sont plus tôt par les
adultes et pas l inverse c'est quelque
chose que vous êtes en mesure de nous
affirmer avec certitude aujourd'hui déjà
il y a très peu d'enfants qui ont été
malades ducobu 19 et les enfants qui ont
été malades ne se sont pas contaminées
dans les écoles les enfants malades se
sont tous contaminés au contact
d'adultes et dans alain terrien leur
cellule familiale puisque c'est au sein
de la cellule familiale qu'il est en
plus d'interactions il n'y a pas eu
d'épidémie de kevin 19 dans les écoles
d'ailleurs il ya des pays dans lesquels
les écoles n'ont pas été fermé et il n'y
a pas eu plus de sniffer une plus de
problèmes qu en france en france il a
fallu fermer les écoles parce qu'il a
fallu confiné parce que l'épidémie est
partie très vite et
les hôpitaux étaient débordés et donc il
a fallu tout fermé laisser les enfants à
la maison
mais maintenant qu'on sort de ce pic
épidémique
c'est les enfants peuvent retourner à
l'école comme cela se passe dans nos
pays dans d'autres pays en europe en
allemagne en suisse en hollande les
enfants retournent à l'école avec des
mesures d'hygiène simples
il ya quand même certains pays justement
j'allais venir nos voisins européens
comme par exemple les italiens qui ont
préféré attendre septembre pour remettre
les enfants à l'école
pour quelle raison dans ce cas ci ce
n'est pas dangereux ils ont de fausses
informations
les mesures prises sont prises par les
gouvernements et chacun prend les
mesures qu'il juge nécessaires l'italie
a été particulièrement touché et il faut
parfois aussi du temps pour se remettre
mais en france nous pouvons reprendre
l'école sans sens sans danger pour les
enfants nous sommes totalement rassurant
pour les enfants alors on voit que la
majorité des parents environ 60 % sont
encore très inquiet et ne compte pas
mettre leurs enfants à l'école
alors c'est vrai que quand on écoute
voilà les médias on lit la presse on
regarde la télévision on entend beaucoup
de choses qui paraissent inquiétants
beaucoup d'experts qui déconseille
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école s'est
rajouté à cela le fameux syndrome de
kawasaki dont on a parlé
est ce que pour vous il ya eu une voix
un petit peu majoritaire qui contribue à
inquiéter les parents en france
nous les pédiatres
nous n'avons pas été nous n'avons pas
inquiéter les parents au début de
l'épidémie nous ne connaissions pas le
coronavirus nous pensions qu'ils se
comportaient un peu comme le virus de la
grippe mais nous avions déjà vu que les
enfants étaient peu malade
la seule inquiétude que nous avions
c'était que les enfants soient comme
pour la grippe des réservoirs à virus et
qu'ils allaient ramener le but
la maison nous savons depuis que cela
n'est pas vrai les enfants sont porteurs
du coc vide 19 et ne sont pas les
réservoirs à virus que l'on pensait
alors les familles ont été beaucoup
inquiété parce que nous avons vécu une
épidémie inédite il ya eu énormément
d'informations mais nous les pédiatres
avons toujours été particulièrement
rassurant concernant les enfants même au
pic de l'épidémie les services de
pédiatrie est évident il n'y avait pas
d'enfants dans les services d'urgence et
nous dans nos cabinets après le début du
confinement les enfants n'étant plus en
collectivité nous ne voyons plus
d'urgence dans nos cabinets donc nous
n'avons jamais alerté les parents par
rapport aux coronavirus et le
coronavirus n'est pas une pathologie
pédiatrique justement ma question c'est
est pourquoi votre voix était aussi peu
audible ces dernières semaines puisque
vous nous confirmez vous n'avez jamais
été inquiet mais c'est vrai que votre
voix celle des pédiatres était assez peu
entendu la preuve 60 % des parents
restent extrêmement inquiet alors il est
sûr que comme cette pathologie touche et
massivement la population adulte
on a beaucoup sur les chaînes sur une
aiguille les médias ont énormément
parler d'eux des hôpitaux sous tension
et la pédiatrie n'a pas été
en première en premier lieu en donc
donc nous avons toujours été rassurant
mais probablement peu entendu nous avons
dès le début de l'épidémie communiqué
sur la nécessité de poursuivre les
vaccination des nourrissons et ça s'est
extrait très important parce que nous
savions que nous allons nous inscrire
sur la durée et qu'il fallait continuer
à vacciner les nourrissons pour ne pas
aller exposer à d'autres pathologies
beaucoup plus grave
le corona virus n'est pas dangereux chez
les enfants par contre si on ne vaccine
pas on risque d'avoir des méningites au
risque d'avoir des coqueluches donc nous
avons dès le début
communiqué sur la nécessité de suivre
les enfants nous avons organisé nos
cabinets pour pouvoir recevoir les
nouveaux nés les petits nourrisson que
nous avons continué à vacciner et après
très rapidement nous avons aussi
communiquer sur la nécessité de sortir
les enfants de l'isolément de pouvoir
éventuellement les sortir un petit peu
mais en période de confinement c'était
compliqué et depuis que l'on parle de
retour de l'école nous sommes tout à
fait confiants sur le retour à l'école
met à tourner derrière question j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure le fameux syndrome
de kawasaki la presse s'en est fait est
qu il ya quelques semaines au moment
d'ailleurs on parlait de de rouvrir les
écoles aujourd'hui c'est un danger que
vous écarter ce qu'on lançait un petit
peu plus déjà ce qu'il est lié aux
coronavirus la maladie de kawasaki est
une maladie que nous pédiatre
connaissons c'est une maladie qui
survient régulièrement après des
infections diverses et variées c'est une
tout simplement à des règles un
dérèglement du système immunitaire de
l'enfant qui fait suite à une agression
infectieuses qui parfois peut être tout
à fait passer inaperçu
l' alerte est liée au fait que
habituellement les services hospitaliers
voit à peu près un cas par mois de plus
maladie de kawasaki et là d'un coup il y
a eu un nombre de cas est levée une
quinzaine puis un peu plus une trentaine
une cinquantaine
à l'hôpital necker notamment il y en a
eu dans d'autres hôpitaux
alors effectivement il y a un lien avec
le coronavirus puisque ces enfants ont
eu une sérologie positive mais c'est
quelque chose qui reste rare
il n'y a pas eu de cas graves c'est
quelque chose qui se soigne il y à un
traitement sont des injections
d'immunoglobuline donc tous ces enfants
sont guéris il y a probablement un lien
mais ce n'est pas grave
et c'est extrêmement rare donc ça ne
change pas notre discours rassurant par
rapport aux familles effectivement ça a
été énormément médiatisé mais c'est
quelque chose qui rares d'oiseaux
restons très rassurant merci beaucoup
fabienne kocher d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt froncés concernant présent
le bilan de l'épidémie du coronavirus la
france compte désormais 27 1425 morts
selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé 351 personnes sont
mortes en 24 heures le nombre de
patients en réanimation continue de
baisser avec 129 malades en moins le
nombre de personnes guéries est sorti de
l'hôpital s'établit lui à 59 1605 depuis
le début de la crise et en italie est
présent pour faire face aux conséquences
de l'épidémie le gouvernement a décidé
de régulariser temporairement des
travailleurs clandestins
ceux qui travaillent dans les domaines
de l'agriculture et de l'aide à domicile
le décret du gouvernement en vise à leur
garantir une couverture santé les
détails avec l âme et medjahed
la régularisation concernerait environ
600 milles sans papiers tous ceux
travaillant illégalement en tant
qu'ouvrier agricole ou comme femme de
ménage et baby sitter depuis au moins le
31 octobre 2019 peuvent demander un
permis de séjour temporaire de 6 mois
mais pour obtenir le précieux sésame
plusieurs conditions sont imposés par
rome
les ressortissants étrangers doivent
auparavant avoir été soumis à des
contrôles photo dactyloscopiques en
clair empreintes digitales et photo
avant le 8 mars 2020 et ne pas avoir
quitté l'italie depuis cette date le
décret du gouvernement vise à offrir à
ses travailleurs sans papiers une
couverture santé et à combattre
l'inégalité
nous sommes arrivés à un résultat
important certainement mais aussi une
bataille de civilisation car je crois
réellement que la dignité des personnes
chez huatai trop centre cela va aussi de
pair avec la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée
celle des marchands d'esclaves modernes
il ya aussi la mise au jour du travail
au noir mais également la sécurité et la
protection
nous sommes dans une situation
épidémiologique d'urgence sanitaire et
pour éviter justement la diffusion du
coronavirus le décret invite communes et
régions à prendre des mesures urgentes
pour garantir la salubrité la sécurité
des logements des migrants concernés une
main-d'oeuvre venus d'afrique du
moyen-orient mais également de pays
européens comme la bulgarie et la
roumanie pour récolter fruits et légumes
ou travailler à domicile
l'italie n'est pas le premier pays en
europe à prendre la décision de
régulariser des migrants fin mars le
gouvernement de gauche du portugal a
pris cette mesure pour permettre aux
étrangers en attente de régularisation
d'accéder aux soins et à toutes les
mesures sociales le temps de la crise
sanitaire duo kobe 10
et pour en parler nous sommes avec météo
ou gisèle bertille rédacteur en chef de
putsch bonsoir météo et merci merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors c'est vrai que la régularisation
des sans papiers s'étaient pas nouvelle
à laquelle on pouvait s'attendre en
italie les encore quelques mois c'est
une surprise pour vous non c'est pas une
surprise parce que ça répond à des
idéologies de gauche qui effectivement
ont été mises en place aussi au portugal
un beau conte dire euros dire que ils
font quelque chose pour la dignité
humaine comme il l'a dit aussi le
président du conseil des ministres
giuseppe compter que vous avez montré en
fait le problème c'est que bien sûr tout
le monde voudrait que les conditions
dans lesquelles elles migrants non
réguliers travail soit meilleur mais ce
n'est pas cette régularisation qui va
résoudre les choses
au contraire c'est un vrai appel à une
invitation à enfreindre la loi parce que
les anciens employeurs qui employer des
personnes en noir en fait doivent s auto
dénoncé c'est là que ce n'est pas
automatique une renaissance que bien sûr
une personne voudrait après avoir des
problèmes avec la loire parce que on ne
sait jamais les gouvernements changent
les règles changent aussi
et puis il faut pas oublier que bien sûr
il faut éviter que une personne
quoiqu'il soit sa nationalité soit
obligé de vivre dans des conditions
insalubres mais le gouvernement italien
oublie que il ya beaucoup d'italiens qui
sont dans ces conditions de misère et
qui misère qui était aggravée par le
coran d'un virus donc ça veut dire quoi
que les italiens eux ne voient pas
forcément ces régularisations d'un d'un
bon oeil on va comprendre ça
ça a été une un argument qui a été
utilisée par les forces de gauche qui
soutient l'actuel gouvernement pour
conduire à répondre à envoyer un message
à leur électorat
mais dans la situation actuelle il ya
effectivement beaucoup d'italiens qui
sont contraires et qui attend des
mesures pour leur quotidien et aussi des
faut pas oublier beaucoup des craintes
migrants qui sont réguliers et qui donc
on fait tous les choses dans le bon sens
quand ils sont arrivés en italie
alors il ya la régularisation évidemment
c'est une chose c'est un départ il faut
ensuite intégrer un c'est son papier
qu'est ce qui est prévu par la suite
parce qu'on le rappelle cette
régularisation elle a un but économique
c'est pour le secteur agricole qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
ensuite quand cette crise sera passée
c'est une belle question effectivement
après l'urgence la crainte que ces
personnes re passe dans la dans le noir
dans une zone de non droit et qui se
retrouve comme on dirait en position de
faiblesse vis-à-vis surtout des mafias
et puis il ne faut pas oublier que parmi
ces régularisations en réalité si on
parle seulement de l'aspect du travail
le décret approuvé par le gouvernement
italien par le site italien qui était un
mois au nook y travailler au noir donc
c'est assez intéressant de voir que ce
ce décret doit essayer de donner des
réponses aussi à des italiens qui depuis
des années on le sait travailler au noir
surtout dans l'agriculture et il
récupère aussi la partie des migrants
mais encore une fois il ne faut pas
oublier qu'ils capitale il ya un taux de
chômage est vraiment important qu'il ya
beaucoup de chômeurs qui ont essayé qui
ont voulu s'est manifesté pour aller
travailler dans les champs
surtout dans cette phase qui ne peut non
pas pu le
le faire parce que c'était plus facile
pour le gouvernement en place à répondre
à une partie de l'électorat qui le
soutient régulière régularisant alors
temporairement les clandestins merci
matteo jose alberti merci à vous et aux
etats unis l'attention tout d'un contre
washington et pékin donald trump menace
désormais de rompre toute relation avec
le géant asiatique une juge responsable
de l'apparition du virus le vieil accuse
également pékin d'espionner ses
chercheurs qui travaillent sur la
recherche d'un vaccin contre le comique
la chine elle dénonce une campagne de
calomnie les explications de lille a
failli nous ou un bras de fer sans fin
entre la chine et les états unis et la
crise du coronavirus accentue un peu
plus chaque jour ce rapport de force
donald trump vient même de déclarer
qu'il n'excluait pas de rompre toutes
relations avec la chine
après avoir longtemps qualifié le coït
19 de virus chinois il a surenchéri il
ya quelques jours en parlant cette fois
ci je cite de la peste de chine
comme je le répète depuis longtemps
traitée avec la chine est très onéreux
nous venions tout juste d'acter un
gigantesque accord commercial lancre
était quasiment sèche que le monde a été
frappée par la piste chinoise
une façon toute personnelle pour le
locataire de la maison blanche de
souligner la responsabilité de pékin
dans la propagation de l'épidémie
depuis des mois l'administration trump
accusent les autorités chinoises d'avoir
tardé à alerter le monde sur l'épidémie
est d'en avoir même dissimulé l'ampleur
pire le président américain et le
secrétaire d'état michael p ô accuse
ouvertement pékin d'avoir dissimulé un
accident dans un laboratoire de wuhan
qui serait selon eux à l'origine de la
pandémie
n'oubliez pas que ce n'est pas la
première fois que la chine infecte le
monde et qu'elle a l'habitude de gérer
des laboratoires ne respectant pas les
normes
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
avons un monde exposé à des virus qui
résultent de défaillance d'un
laboratoire chinois
si le discours se durcit les
cision se font-elles aussi de plus en
plus musclé à l'égard de la chine
donald trump multiplie ainsi les mesures
de rétorsion à l'égard du géant
asiatique
dernière en date l'interdiction pour le
système de retraites des fonctionnaires
américains de procéder à l'achat de
titres financiers chinois
désormais c'est sur le plan de
l'espionnage industriel que
l'administration américaine s'en prend à
pékin le fbi et l'agencé américaine de
cybersécurité accuse des pirates
informatiques soit disons affiliés à la
chine de cibler des organisations
américaines chargées de la recherche sur
le coït 19
ces acteurs ont été surpris en train de
tenter d'identifier et d'acquérir
illégalement auprès de réseaux et
d'individus impliqués dans la recherche
contre le corry 19 des données liées aux
vaccins aux traitements et aux tests
le vol potentiel de ces informations
menace la mise à disposition d'options
de traitement sûr et efficace
de son côté pékin dénonce des calories
loin des mets pas un abus la chine
exprime son vif mécontentement et sa
ferme opposition à une telle diffamation
de la part des états unis
à en juger par les antécédents des états
unis ont mené les plus grandes
opérations de cyber vols dans le monde
la chine a réalisé des avancées
stratégiques importants dans sa lutte
contre l'épidémie ducobu 19
elle a également été en tête du monde en
matière de recherche et de traitement du
vaccin contre le kobe 19
par conséquent la chine a plus de raison
que d'autres de s'inquiéter du
cyberespionnage in se trouve un coming
out en chine dans onenote chimie pour le
professeur wayne ces attaques
américaines sont avant tout une
tentative pour faire oublier une gestion
catastrophique de l'épidémie et à ce
jour aux états unis plus de 80000
personnes sont mortes et bientôt il y
aura davantage de morts et gestion des
c'est la vérité ils n'ont pas réussi à
protéger leur peuple et veulent rejeter
cette responsabilité il faut donc de la
chine leur bouc émissaire mais ce qu à
moins de six mois de la présidentielle
américaine donald trump est très
critiqué pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire et le président américain n'a
sans doute
rien contre le fait que les électeurs
puissent reporter leur colère contre la
chine mais prolonger l'épreuve de force
avec l' empire du milieu pourrait avoir
des conséquences sur l'économie
américaine
autre élément qui pèsera certainement
lors du scrutin du 3 novembre
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis atlanta avec ben swan journaliste
d'investigation c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir un bon soir ben
swan merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france donc on le voit la tension
monte sérieusement entre pékin et
washington donald trump menace même
maintenant de ne plus parler à la chine
est ce que c'est un simple bluff selon
vous où on est vraiment en présence d'un
vrai risque de rupture diplomatique
lorsqu'on parle du présent train on ne
peut jamais savoir la plupart du temps
ils l'aiment effectivement bluffé il
aime dire qu'il va faire des choses et
ensuite changé d'avis mais nous avons
également vu par le passé qu'il a dit
des choses à propos de la chine par
exemple en matière de commerce et il a
respecté ses engagements
donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il va arriver
est ce que les états unis seront aussi
stricte avec la chine que le présent le
dit on il essayait d'imposer des tarifs
punitifs à la chine c'est très possible
il faut garder à l'esprit que pour le
moment le président essaye de gérer la
crise dans son pays et les médias sont
extrêmement cruel avec lui concernant
ces actions est ce que l'on considère
comme ses échecs
le président doit donc pouvoir accuser
quelqu'un d'autre et la chine semblent
une cible privilégiée
alors on rappelle à l'origine de ces
tensions washington qui accuse pékin
d'ailleurs depuis le début d'avoir caché
la gravité de ce virus là ça va plus
loin on parle d'avoir caché cet accident
dans le laboratoire de one qui serait à
l'origine de la pandémie
pourquoi s'acharner sur ces accusations
maintenant quel est l'intérêt de donald
trump
voilà au lieu de gérer la crise est
peut-être régler ses comptes après
pourquoi maintenant c'est une très bonne
question et je pense qu'une partie du
problème c'est que la gestion de la
crise semble dépassée qui que ce soit à
washington quand j'ai une tonne le fait
que réagir ne gère rien du tout il ne
contrôle rien du tout donc si l'on
observe ce qui se passe à washington en
ce moment en matière d'antennes
économique
c'est effectivement des réactions et pas
des actions décisives ils sont à la
traîne par rapport à la crise nous ne
testons pas encore de manière
systématique aux états unis cet
incroyable lorsque on voit l'argent dont
bénéficient les états unis
l'argent que nous sommes en train
d'imprimer et pourtant ne pouvons pas
encore mené des tests mais bon ça nous
fait une idée des anticorps et combien
de personnes ont des anticorps d'un
système en ce moment même donc le fait
que les politiques ne sont pas
conditionnées par les sciences où les
données sont dus au fait qu'il n'a pas
assez pour le moment cela fait deux mois
que la crise a commencé nous sommes
encore bien trop en retard donc je pense
que l'administration est vraiment
désemparés ne sait pas comment faire
pour prendre de l'avancé par rapport à
la crise et le pensent qu'aux élections
à venir
comment transformer présenter la chose
afin que lors des élections nous
confions nous puissions défendre notre
action les américains aiment l'idée
d'avoir un ailier comme un quelqu'un qui
est en fait dans le monstre qu'il faut
arrêter et donald trump joue là dessus
c'est la chine le monstre c'est eux qui
ont créé le virus donc toutes les
conséquences sont imputables de la chine
alors on en a parlé tout à l'heure il ya
aussi maintenant les accusations
d'espionnage selon laquelle les hackers
chinois auraient tenté de s'emparer de
recherche d' american sur le vaccin
alors là ce n'est pas de donald trump a
mais le fbi et le département de la
sécurité intérieure qui sont à l'origine
de ces accusations est ce qu'elles
semblent juger
crédible notamment aux états unis cela
ne semble pas forcément crédible nous
avons donc entendus pour parler de
hackers et de piratage vous avez entendu
parler de hackers russes lors des
élections de 2016 et au cours des
semaines dernière on en a encore parlé
et cela s'est avéré fraude grâce à des
documents qui viennent d'être publiés la
semaine passée donc il y à une crise de
confiance s'agissant de beaucoup
d'accusations des autorités légales de
ce pays ils le publient pas leurs
informations il ne donne pas de preuves
ils disent des choses et disent que
c'est la vérité et le public commence à
se méfier mais il ya un problème plus
important c'est que blâmer la chine peut
présenter des avantages politiques comme
mais je ne pense pas que sur le long
terme cela aura du succès car nous avons
des millions de de d'américains au
chômage des millions d'américains qui
demandent des prestations chômage
il ya des milliers également de
l'entrepreneur qui n'ont pas encore reçu
dette
donc il s'en fiche de qui est
responsable ils veulent des réponses
quant à la façon dont on va les aider
eux et malheureusement washington ne
réussit pas à apporter ses réponses au
niveau du président mais également au
niveau du congrès est en ligne de mire
évidemment la présidentielle de novembre
merci à vous ben swan d'avoir été avec
mon journaliste d'investigation quand
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la polémique autour
du vaccin contre le commis 19 les états
unis seraient prioritaires des
déclarations de sanofi qui n'ont pas
manqué de faire réagir
jusqu'à l'elysée puis ce sera les dites
aux échos sur le retour au travail en
france avec le dégonflement devront nous
dire adieu aux congés payés et aux rtt
faudra-t-il travailler plus nous verrons
à ce qu'on pense jacques sapir
[Musique]
oui
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
prasad ce type de pratique il existe sur
la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si seul un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
il est beaucoup plus facile de faire de
la dette le qui sera réglée par nous
plus tard par nos enfants plus tard les
pays les plus pauvres ne rembourseront
pas donc garder une créance dans le
bilan au passé qu'elle sera jamais
remboursé c'est c'est même pas hypocrite
ça n'a pas de sens on a pas de
croissance et on a une dette qui ont
d'ailleurs pas lui mettre une note de
dette ont effectivement à la manne aux
créanciers vous appartenez à celui qui
me prêtent de l'argent soit l'état soit
une banque mais vous lui appartenait
totalement pour christine lagarde la
patronne de la bce l'animation de la
dette ne serait ce que partiel est
totalement impensable c'est pas si
facile 2 nuls et la dette et la limite
ses poires c'est la planche à billets
qui aura en contrepartie
[Musique]
on va parler évidemment de l'impact
économique de cette pandémie est ce que
tous les pays africains vont être
impactés continuant voit vraiment une de
ses pires années de ses tantes dernière
même si les conséquences sont
différentes selon les pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de l'activité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par les crises alimentaires dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses ça c'est
la troisième crise est là par la
solitaire est hélas la crise économique
nous allons avoir une crise de sécurité
alimentaire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour une demi heure d'information
deuxième heure d'émission il est 21h
heure de paris toute vie voici les types
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 14 mai sanofi
appelle l'europe à partager les risques
pour produire un vaccin
le laboratoire a provoqué une levée de
boucliers en laissant entendre que les
etats unis bénéficierez du vexin en
premier même s'il france patrons
français tente de rassurer en affirmant
qu'il sera accessible à tous en même
temps
emmanuel macron lui jugé nécessaire que
ce vaccin soit un bien public mondial
extraits des lois du marché la question
du retour au travail après le
déconfinement de l'action en justice de
la cgt contre une usine de renault
propositions chocs de l'institut
montaigne pour rebondir les vieilles
querelles ce ressurgissent alors devront
nous dire adieu aux congés payés rtt
faudra-t-il travailler plus l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre à
toutes ces questions dans sa chronique
est qu à 21h15
[Musique]
un mot tout d'abord sur le bilan de
l'épidémie coronavirus en france la
barre des 27 mille morts a été franchi
selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé
trois cent cinquante et une personnes
sont mortes en 24 heures le nombre de
patients en réanimation continue de
baisser avec 129 malades en moins le
nombre de personnes guéries est sorti de
l'hôpital s'établit à 59 1605 depuis le
début de l'épidémie
alors qui aura le premier axe est un
éventuel vaccin contre le coït 19 la
question semble être sur toutes les
lèvres aujourd'hui parmi les
laboratoires dans les starting blocks
pour le produire
le français sanofi mais son directeur
général a mis le feu aux poudres
aujourd'hui suggérant un accès
prioritaire pour les états unis
des propos qui ont suscité de nombreuses
réactions au sein de la classe politique
française mais également au sein du
gouvernement
la déclaration du patron de sanofi a
beaucoup ému le président de la
république
les efforts déployés ces derniers mois
montre qu'il est nécessaire que ce
vaccin soit un bien public mondial
extraits des lois du marché j'ai appelé
de pdg de sanofi france pour lui
demander des explications
il m'a dit que ce ne reflétait pas du
tout la politique de son laboratoire et
qu'il avait communiqués ce qu'il a
d'ailleurs fait pour bien expliquer que
toutes les populations qui doivent
bénéficier du vaccin bénéficieront du
vaccin et pour en parler nous sommes
avec pierre dharréville députés pcf du
13e as their 13e pendant circonscription
des bouches-du-rhône bonsoir pierre
dharréville merci d'être avec nous vous
avez présenté à l'assemblée le 20 avril
une proposition de loi pour un service
public du médicament
que vous inspirent les derniers
développements la réaction de sanofi de
vouloir favoriser les états unis c'est
évidemment scandaleux parce qu'on voit
bien que on est au coeur de la
marchandisation de la santé et la
politique de sanofi correspond à cela
c'est à dire qu'on cherche finalement
toujours à faire du profit et a dîné
avec les uns avec les autres
je crois que franchement ça n'est pas
sérieux de manière générale et y compris
là on voit bien ça ça nous apparaît de
manière encore plus évidente à bord de
cette fois profité à toutes et à tous il
s'agit pas simplement de donner aux plus
offrants
alors c'est ce qu'a dit en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a affirmé le patron français
voulait rassurer dire voilà ça sera
accessible à tous
mais est ce que finalement c'est
possible de rendre avec sa accessible à
tous tout simplement s n'est ce pas un
voeu pieux c'est tout à fait possible ça
d'ailleurs
existait il ya des vaccins qui sont tout
à fait disponible qui est que chacun
peut maintenant produire et donc voilà
je crois que c'est tout à fait
nécessaire pour le vaccin du commis 19
qui pour l'instant n'existe hélas pas
encore mais qui est en cours de
recherche
j'espère qu'il qu'il adviendra un jour
le problème c'est que si vous voulez les
déclarations parce qu'elle a eu une
précédente de la scène quand même le
trouble il a beau avoir un peu rétro
pédaler depuis aujourd'hui on se dit
quand même qu'il ya un certain
discussions engagées dans lesquelles
sanofi et essaye de passer ses pions et
de voilà toujours avec cette même quête
finalement de profiter or là nous avons
je crois quand même un besoin essentiel
qui nous est commun à toute l'humanité
haas auquel on peut pas faire ce type de
calcul ça n'est pas sérieux ce n'est pas
possible il faut que lui fois que le
vaccin sera découverte je ne sais pas
par qui il puisse sa composition sa
formule c'est sa fabrication puis sat
rendue publique afin que un peu partout
on puisse le fabriqué dans de bonnes
conditions je crois que l'om est
meilleur garant
tous avaient alors ce que dit sanofi
c'est que tout simplement on a besoin de
partager les risques pour produire les
doses nécessaires et en clair les états
unis apportent beaucoup plus de soutien
financier que l'europe donc en gros
c'est à eux d'en profiter
en premier ça vous met en colère ce
genre de raisonnement extrêmement
réaliste voire cynique
oui bien sûr une forme d'égoïsme qui
aimait profondément révoltant et
inacceptable compris de la part du jeu
demandeurs ce sont les états unis moi je
ne demande pas à ce qu'ils aient la
priorité à la france voit que le sujet
n'est pas là nous avons un problème dans
notre capacité de production de
médicaments je trouve ça que j'ai tenu
j'ai proposé ça te cette loi qui n'a pas
été encore débattue mais cela étant dit
la chance à payer beaucoup et nous avons
donné l'année dernière j'ai 30 78 30
millions d'euros à sanofi de crédit
impôt recherche sanofi les médicaments
de sanofi sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale pour une large part
quand même hein donc voilà je crois
qu'il faut et puis sanofi à verser des
dividendes aux actionnaires je crois que
c'était 4 milliards d'euros d'année
l'année dernière je suis bien c'est
considérable
faut pas nous raconter des histoires
c'est pas comme ça que les choses
doivent fonctionner mais je pense qu'il
est temps maintenant de remettre de
l'ordre dans la production du médicament
de remettre de la démocratie là dedans
et de remettre de la transparence
emmanuel macron a réagi aujourd'hui il
souhaite extraire le vaccin du bien
public mondial il va d'ailleurs
rencontré la direction de sanofi
prochainement qu'est ce que vous
attendez
concrètement du président de la
république dans cette affaire je crois
qu'il faut taper du poing sur la table
il faut exiger effectivement que le
vaccin qui sera découvert puisse être un
bien commun des mois je pense que sanofi
avant la crise avaient déjà commencé à
délocaliser non seulement de la
production sa vente des médicaments que
nous produisions ici mais le sens qu
aujourd'hui et à délocaliser aussi la
recherche
je crois qu'il faut taper du poing sur
la table on a parlé beaucoup de
relocaliser un certain nombre de
productions celle du médicament a fait
partie et je crois que il faut que nous
lui donnions un outil c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait cette proposition de loi que
nous tenions un outil donc il faudra le
dire à sanofi préfère m'en de production
publique de médicaments
je crois qu'il ya là matière maintenant
ça paraît comme une évidence pas
simplement laisser le marché sanofi les
grandes ligues pharma décider de
l'avenir de notre société
clairement cette crise pour vous pierre
dharréville a réveillé a révélé
des failles dans le marché du médicament
en france
oui d'abord il y avait des paies le
début des pénuries qui se sont qui se
sont révélés qui ont exposé 1
d'année en année les pénuries augmenté à
1200 médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur sont trouvés en tension où une
pénurie
l'année dernière je crois que c'était
huit cents l'année précédente seulement
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée donc on
a véritablement un succès sur l'
organisation la production de
médicaments se faire plus tendu qui se
délocalisent
on peut pas vouloir gérer comme ça ils
médicaments simplement pour optimiser
les profits ça n'est pas possible ça
n'est pas sérieux et je crois que c'est
pour cela qu'il faut les remettre de la
démocratie là dedans remettent aussi de
l'intervention publique
on peut pas simplement laisser quelques
actionnaires décider notre stratégie en
matière de sentiers et de médicaments
est-ce qu'ils sont clairement aussi que
l'état reprenne la main sur les
laboratoires oui il ya eu d'une certaine
façon il faut il faut reprendre la main
et les jeux il ya déjà on lave et rien
pour un certain nombre de laboratoires
qui se trouvaient en difficulté je pense
à ça marche du côté de nyon qui
produisent et où ce médicament d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et qui était en
liquidation judiciaire qui aurait dû je
pense qu'ils ont repris pour pouvoir
continuer cette production là mais je
pense qu'à chaque fois que nécessaire
soit pas se priver de faire grossir un
outil de production public qui soit
suffisamment forte pour répondre à nos
besoins en cas de crise mais qui pèse
aussi sur le marché du médicament qui le
rendent plus vertueux qui oblige les big
pharmas et bien se comporter autrement
parce que s'ils ne le font pas et bien
il y aura une petite production public
sur la classe qui sera l'europe
merci père d'arrivée d'avant était avec
nous en direct sur rt france serré
et avec le déconfinement la question du
retour au travail de l'action justice de
la cgt contre une usine de renault aux
propositions chocs de l'institut
montaigne pour rebondir
les vieilles querelles ressurgissent in
que le monde d'après n'est peut-être pas
pour tout de suite
en attendant devront nous dire adieu aux
congés payés ou rtt faudra-t-il
travailler plus pour gagner moins
on voit ça tout de suite avec notre
économie sachs est pire que l'on
retrouve aujourd'hui encore via skype
bon soit en rack vous vous êtes des cons
filet avec prudence on espère oui c'est
fanny bonjour avec les gestes barrières
bien entendu alors jacques ce
déconfinement on en parle c'est donc
travailler plus pour gagner moins
oui c'est la grande question du moment
stéphanie alors effectivement à écouter
au l'institut montaigne ou encore
christian jacob le patron des
républicains
on peut penser que c'est ce qui nous
attend et en même temps vous voyez moi
aussi j'ai été contaminé par notre
président donc et en même temps nous
avons cette action en justice intentée
par la cgt qui a fait fermer l'usiné
renault de sandouville
alors tout ça a bien effectivement un
petit goût du monde d'avant dans le
monde d'après alors jacques à commençons
d'abord par l'action de la cgt
comment peut-on faire faire fermer une
usine alors qu'on les rouvre un peu
partout stéphanie la cgt a considéré que
et la justice d'ailleurs sur ce point
lui a donné raison que les conditions
techniquement n'avaient pas été réunies
dans cette reprise de l'activité chez
renault alors au delà d'un conflit entre
syndicats et on voit très bien qu'il ya
un conflit entre la cgt et la cfdt
compliqué donc tout à fait réelle ya en
réalité un problème qui est plus profond
en 2017 et 2018
la ministre du travail madame muriel
pénicaud dans sa réforme du code du
travail a décidé de remplacer les divers
comités existants dans les entreprises
par des comités sociaux économiques
rappellent les 16e et c 'est ce était
censée fusionner alors à la fois les
anciens délégués du personnel
les comités d'hygiène et de sécurité
le comité d'entreprise cette réforme
très concrètement a abouti à diminuer le
poids des représentants du personnel
dans l'entreprise et dans le cas de
renault
on peut penser que si le comité
d'hygiène et sécurité avait toujours
existé
on aurait un meilleur cadre pour la
discussion et vendrait peut-être pu
éviter d'en arriver à une action en
justice
oui c'est un exemple ou la réforme du
code du travail
loin d'améliorer le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise
là en réalité beaucoup compliqué alors
fait qu'elles n'ont plus loin ce que
propose au contraire à l'institut
montaigne même si ces boulots évidemment
est ce que cela ne ne s'impose pas dans
la situation actuelle
stéphanie oui nous sommes évidemment
dans une situation exceptionnelle
personne ne le nie le pib qui mesure la
richesse nationale va reculer d'environ
10 % peut-être plus sur l'ensemble de
l'année et personne ne dit non plus que
le plus dur soit à venir et qui pourrait
y avoir une vague de chômeurs au second
semestre
mais qu'est ce que propose réellement
l'institut montaigne
alors tout d'abord il veut augmenter le
temps de travail pour rattraper le temps
perdu lors du confinement bon or pour
cela il dit est l'un de ceux conduits là
je cite le rapport le principal frein
aujourd'hui à l'augmentation du temps de
travail réside dont le surcoût que
représente l'accroissement du temps de
travail pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui la loi impose une majoration
aussi bien pour les heures
supplémentaires que pour les rachats des
jours de rtt
ce qui veut dire que l'institut
montaigne veut faire sauter le plafond
des heures supplémentaires et modifier
leurs rémunérations mais aussi
s'attaquer au principe des rtt et des 35
heures est sur les 35 heures est qu'il
n'est pas le seul à le dire oui tout à
fait c'est fini christian jacob le
président des républicains a déclaré
lundi 11 mai donc il ya quelques jours
qu'il fallait sortir de ce qu'il appelle
le carcan des 35 heures
il n'est pas le premier et il n'est pas
le seul d'ailleurs à tenir ce genre de
discours
seulement voilà quand on sait que les
français travaillent en réalité non pas
35 heures
mais 38 heures 10 on voit que ce à quoi
s'attaque christian jacob
c'est au paiement des heures
supplémentaires
en fait la volonté de réformer le
système des 35 heures permettrait aux
entreprises de payer les 38 heures 10
supplémentaires que font en moyenne les
salariés au même tarif que les heures
précédentes
c'est donc une mesure qui entraînerait
une baisse des rémunérations
bref c'est le travailler plus pour
gagner moins
alors jacques elle désolée c'est mon
rôle là je reviens à la charge tout de
même est ce que ce n'est pas nécessaire
aujourd'hui actuellement a dit stéphanie
si nous étions dans une situation de
plein emploi
on pourrait peut-être en discuter selon
le chômage est important en france et
d'ailleurs il va augmenter dans les
semaines qui viennent
vous prenez tout simplement les
catégories a aidé de pôle emploi
c'est l'écran qui sont sans emploi
demandeurs d'emploi sans emploi
nous avons d'ores et déjà 3,6 millions
de personnes sans emploi
et si on y ajoute les 770 milles
personnes qui sont employées pour moins
d'un mi-temps autrement dit moins de 20
heures par semaine contre leur volonté
on obtient 4,3 millions de personnes qui
constitue en réalité les chômeurs réels
alors même si on ne prend en compte que
les personnes qui sont strictement sans
emploi
cela reste au-dessus des 11%
on le voit par exemple sur le tableau
qui est ici présentée on le voit que
cela peu de sens de demander à ceux qui
travaillent de travailler plus
quand il y a tant de personnes qui
recherchent un emploi c'est même en
réalité assez incohérent dans la
situation actuelle
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par
l'aja quel est votre arrière pensée on
vous connaît alors bon arrière pensée
stéphanie sait que admettons que l'on
applique les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne ou celle de
christian jacob
qu'est-ce qui se passe la rémunération
des personnes employées besré puisque
c'est explicitement ce que veut
l'institut montaigne les heures
supplémentaires ne seraient plus
rémunérés au tarif normal et une partie
des rtt ne serez plus compensés et rien
n'empêcherait par ailleurs les
entreprises de faire travailler les gens
heures voire plus il n'y aurait donc
plus aucun effet d'appel sur les
chômeurs mais en plus la demande toutes
choses égales par ailleurs de ce trait
et en quoi cette baisse de la demande
serait un problème c'est que la baisse
de la demande
elle se cumuleraient elle se cumulera en
réalité avec la volonté et des ménages
d'épargné plus stéphanie les chansons
inquiet il faut les comprendre
le confinement a été un choc
psychologique majeur pour la majorité de
la population
si on regarde la chine et c'est
intéressant parce que la chine cd
confiné avant nous seuls les plus riches
ont repris leur consommation d'avant
l'épidémie les classes moyennes et
moyennes inférieures elles ont réduit
leur consommation
en réalité pour augmenter leur épargne
or si la demande baisse le niveau de
l'économie mais aussi d'autant plus
qu'il est illusoire de penser que dans
une situation mondiale de crise
il pourrait y avoir une forte demande
extérieure pour nos exportations
et c'est là que l'on voit se dessiner le
risque de tsunami du chômage vous savez
on considère que ce dernier augmentera
probablement de 500000 personnes d'ici
au début de cet automne seulement en cas
de crise massive de la demande nous
pourrions bien dépasser le million de
chômeurs voire peut-être même atteindre
les 2 millions de chômeurs en plus et
fac c'est pour cette raison que vous
n'approuvez pas les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne
et oui c'est fini vous savez la
différence entre la situation post
confinement et celle de l'après guerre
en 1945 c'est que l'appareil de
production est intacte dans une france
en ruines ce qui était le cas en 1945 le
fameux retrouve chez vos manches de
maurice thorez
le dirigeant communiste pouvait
parfaitement se comprendre lui
aujourd'hui la question est bien plus
celle de la demande
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de la demande
des ménages ou qu'il s'agisse de la
demande publique
la véritable question qui se pose n'est
pas c'est du travail mais celle de la
relance
or il faut quand même en parler
les projets actuels du gouvernement sont
complètement inadéquat sur ce point
prenons le prenons d'abord le plan
relance le prendre un rôle de la relance
ne sera annoncé qu'en septembre prochain
c'est beaucoup trop tard il risque d'y
avoir d'ici la fin du mois d'août un
massacre dans les entreprises en
particulier dans les petites entreprises
durant cet été il faudrait si on était
raisonnable que ce plan soit annoncée
dès la mi juin au 1er juillet au plus
tard et puis les sommes que veut engager
le gouvernement sont décidément trop
faible alors bruno le maire parle
beaucoup des 110 milliards de prêts vu
se bat ce qu'ils oublient de dire est ce
qu'on oublie en règle générale c'est que
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent frais
dans ses 110 milliards en fait il y en a
pas plus de 45 milliards
au mieux il faudrait au moins le double
de cette somme peut être même le triple
si on veut qu'une demande intérieure
solide et durable se substitue à la
demande étrangère qui elle alors ça on
en est sûr sera défaut alors en
conclusion jacques verrier que
l'institut montaigne se trompe de cible
tout à fait c'est fanny tout à fait et
c'est bien ça le problème
ils raisonnent comme si on était face à
d'immenses destructions matérielles
voilà comme si on manquait de
travailleurs seulement nous ne sommes
pas confrontés à l'une de ces deux
situations
du fait du chômage c'est en réalité l'un
vers ce qui se passe il faut trouver du
travail pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
en plus particulièrement pour tout ceux
qui vont perdre le la du fait des
conséquences de confinement dans ce
contexte c'est une
c'est une politique de demandes qu'il
faut faire et pas une politique de
l'offre parce que cette politique de
l'offre qui est en réalité une
caricature de politique de l'offre est
non seulement inadéquate mais pourrait
même contribuer à aggraver de manière
tout à fait considérable la crise
économique que nous allons vivre dans
les prochains mois merci jacques sapir à
par satellite aux échos qui en fera
réfléchir plus d'un merci la direction
présents les états unis où la reprise
sera plus lente qu'espéré selon la fed
la banque centrale américaine
en deux mois à la crise sanitaire et
économique a détruit plus de 33 millions
d'emplois à près de trois millions de
nouveaux inscrits au chômage en une
semaine les états unis ou le cap des 80
4000 morts a été franchi avec 1800 13
nouveaux décès en 24 heures c'est le
pays le plus touché au monde par le
virus
malgré ces chiffres plusieurs états
américains continuent de lever les
mesures de confinement france métisse
qui évite ch
quarante-sept jours que les plages de
los angeles n'avait pas accueilli de
public et de surfer la seconde ville des
etats unis a décidé d'assouplir le
confinement en autorisant la réouverture
des plages mais aussi de certains petits
commerces pour des ventes à emporter
oui je suis surprise je ne sais pas
pourquoi il n'y a pas plus de monde ici
c'est étrange mais bon on peut penser
que les gens essaient de rester prudent
ce qui concerne leurs activités en
public une faible affluence qui
s'explique peut-être par les
déclarations de la directrice de la
santé publique du comté de los angeles
avertissant que des mesures de
confinement pour rester en vigueur dans
la ville jusqu'au mois de juillet
progressivement et en ordre dispersé les
états continuent à lever les mesures de
confinement une partie de la virginie de
l'état du maryland doit rouvrir ce
vendredi tandis que le confinement de
washington qui devait s'achever fin de
semaine est prolongée jusqu'à début juin
dans l'état du wisconsin
la cour suprême a elle décidé d'annuler
la décision de prolonger le confinement
une décision qui a dû plaire à donald
trump le président américain milite pour
un redémarrage rapide de l'économie
américaine et la réouverture des écoles
je pense que vous devriez absolument
ouvrir les écoles notre pays doit se
remettre en route et il doit le faire le
plus vite possible et je ne pense pas
que notre pays reprendra ses des écoles
sont fermées
sait-on situation inhabituelle locaux
vides 19 a eu très peu d'impact sur les
jeunes et je dirais fermement qu'il faut
ouvrir
il appartient aux gouverneurs de le
faire c'est le choix des gouverneurs
mais leur état n'est pas ouvert si les
écoles ne sont pas ouvertes une reprise
économique devra attendre le président
de la banque centrale américaine évoque
des dégâts durables sur l'économie de la
première puissance mondiale avec ce
chiffre 20 millions de personnes ont
perdu leur emploi en moins de deux mois
aux états unis est toujours à l'étranger
plus précisément en israël après
plus d'un an de crise politique le
gouvernement d'union prêtera finalement
serment dimanche soir la knesset
gaby ashkenazi l'ancien chef de l'armée
israélienne et ténors du parti centriste
bleu blanc devrait être nommé chef de la
diplomatie
et hier le secrétaire d'état américain
mike en paix ou en visite à jérusalem a
rencontré ma gamine netanyahu les deux
hommes ont évoqué plusieurs dossiers
dont celui de l'iran et du plan de paix
de donald trump
il y un problème dans notre région qui
est l'agression et la terreur iranienne
constante mais je voudrais exprimer ma
gratitude pour la position ferme que le
président trump vous même et votre
administration avait adoptées contre
l'iran
premièrement vous retirant du dangereux
accord sur l'iran deuxièmement en
affrontant les maîtres de la terreur
iranienne mars
troisièmement en souhaitant prolonger
l'embargo sur les armes contre l'iran
nous avons eu l'occasion de parler du
projet de paix quelques mois après votre
visite à washington où le président
trump annoncé son projet de paix vous
étiez n'est ce pas il ya encore du
travail et nous devons avancer et je
m'en réjouis
et c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans 30 minutes trente bonnes
minutes même pour un point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
il est beaucoup plus facile de faire de